yes I see that you're three inches
taller now all right Ronnie Ronnie
welcome back to LA yeah so so time last
time we spoke was what probably last
fall right mm-hmm just before
Thanksgiving yes and and what's going on
since like could you were leaving just a
couple days after I told you um so
what's been going on since then I left
after the day after Thanksgiving is when
I got my Texas your family yes my family
picked me up and I was staying with a
family friend for a little bit see it
took about till I know I got on
methadone on December 9th and I've been
on methadone before but I've it's kind
of one of those things I was on and off
doing and I got back on it and from then
I was just continuing to try and get
into rehab and it was I think it was
just a little bit difficult because of
the seasons and when I called I told my
methadone counselor that I was trying to
get into this place called Nexus
recovery the one I had been in when I
was pregnant and it devastated me
because they told me that I wasn't gonna
be able to get into the program and I
just I I remember that feeling of just
like dang you know I'm not gonna be able
to go in you couldn't get in why me just
because the last time and the program I
wanted to be in was PB WC which was
parents and women and women with
children and pregnant women and that
program because your son is when you go
over yes he's one years old now um I was
the last time I had been that program I
was nine months pregnant the year before
I got it out
December 15th of 2018
I had my son January 13th of
19 and when I called they told me that I
wasn't gonna be able to get in for the
simple fact that I don't have custody of
my child and I'm not pregnant
and the program that they wanted me to
be in was a W which is adult women and
that program is two weeks that's not
enough time but that is enough time for
me to get healthy and go back out on a
run is what I look at it as it's just
ridiculous
had you been to rehab how many times
though this was gonna be my was 16th 16
Thurs yeah this my I've lost count I
know it's either 16th or my 17th time
and goodness gracious so many rehabs all
right rehabs detox is all of that wait
listen I'm not gonna go back and recount
all of them whatever whatever the last
video was it's one more than that it
doesn't say but um so after that I
remember going home from the methadone
clinic and just crying to my mom like
you know they're not gonna take me and
you know I really knew this program I
really need it and my mom I just asked
her you know what you pray with me and
I'm kind of not really the most
religious person ever but I remember
asking her to pray with me and we prayed
right before she dropped me back off and
the next day when she went to help to
pick me up to go back to the clinic she
uh she was telling me you know not to be
too down about it there's just other
rehabs you know what she's gonna give it
a second to get some time and I remember
when I went to the methadone clinic that
day my counselor told me hey all right
are you gonna be ready December 23rd and
I said December 23rd for what and he
said they're gonna admit you to the PP
WC program so I ended up getting the
program I wanted and I ended up
committing the first day to do the the
90 days instead of just the 30
when I got there I remember it was kind
of like a little struggle getting
admitted and it just I started to get
really anxious about it and I was having
like really bad anxiety my I was gonna
have a panic attack I was gonna have a
panic attack on the way over there look
in the car it was just me and my dad and
I was just like oh you know I just felt
like my the tightness in my chest like
it was just hurt just going to rehab it
what yeah it was it was the it was the
thought of like you know I know I can do
this I've been off heroin before I've
been clean you know I know it was only
only six months but to me that was a lot
because I've never tried before
and I just I knew I could do it I knew I
had it in me but I was afraid that I was
gonna fail
so after I got dropped off that was on
the 23rd the the next few weeks 70 being
in rehab was really difficult for me
because I think I I had been too hard on
myself you know I was just like I was so
terrified of messing up again and
relapsing that I wasn't giving myself
the opportunity to really try you know
to excel to to ask for help to be happy
so I I spent a lot of my time in rehab
alone in my room crying I felt so I was
at a point where I just felt so low
and I was I felt like I just I had no
strength you know to get myself back up
or maybe it was just the fact that I
didn't want to get back up you know I
remember me telling you in the last
video about the kidnapping and I had I
had been struggling really hard with
PTSD at this point and I'm talking like
there's a specific pair of flip-flops
that I would see that this girl had and
it was the exact same flip-flops that I
had wore here when I had first became
homeless and they had picked me up and
and took me to that hotel it was that
same pair of sandals I went haywire my
my brain went into that fight-or-flight
mode
you know like I have to I have to get
out of here I have to get out of here
after get out of here like they're
coming someone's watching they're gonna
get me and this is a 100% sober you know
because of course I'm in rehab and I I
was constantly checking the shower
curtains to see if somebody was behind
them checking under my bed before I went
to sleep I would I would go as far as
like looking down the create the crack
between the wall and my mattress at
nighttime because of how afraid I was
and that that was caught like costing a
lot of energy for me it was it was
draining me completely and that went on
for the whole time I was in rehab
unsurprisingly I was being bullied at
rehab I'm a 22 year old being bullied by
thirty and forty year old women and it
hurt because it was my first day of
rehab you know the first thing I got
there everybody was just hating on me
nobody wanted to talk to me and you know
I was trying to talk to people and it
just it didn't work out you know people
were just constantly
hating on me you know I could hear them
talking about me you know like you don't
even know me I've been here for for a
couple weeks now two weeks you've never
once talked to me you don't even know my
name
you know what my first my middle my
first name I'm gonna lean or my last
name but you hate me so much and I'm
just I'm nasty I'm disgusting
I'm a hoe because what because the guy
that you think is SuperDuper hot that is
in Narcotics Anonymous says hello to me
every single day because I know them
from the previous years I was here and
it was just little things like that like
that they just hated on me for so I had
no friends in rehab and I think that
also fueled my PTSD you know with
everybody knowing each other and me not
knowing any of them you know I felt like
they were just coming against me and um
like I said I gotta admit into rehab the
23rd of December and I was kicked out of
rehab on the 7th of January I believe no
there's a 21st I was there like not even
a month like a little less than a month
um I was kicked out of rehab I remember
like I I was just bawling my eyes out
because what had happened was this girl
these two women they were like 40 years
old you know they've got children and
they had clicked up and one day one of
the girls it was midnight and she woke
up and she wanted to get a snack and the
tech was like cool like just come to the
closet so I decided oh cool can I have a
snack as well so I went in there and I
got some Oreos and the very next morning
which was Sunday the same girl that had
gotten that we had gotten cookies
together at the same time looked at me
and said don't ever try and get don't
ever try and mess up what I got going on
what
I'm going to get snacks and I looked at
her and I said we're all allowed to get
snacks you know it's not like I took
what you wanted you went in front of me
and she the one she did it she tried to
do it in front of everybody you know
Sunday morning we're all getting ready
for church and we're in the butt Hut
which is where we have to smoke our
cigarettes and she says it in front of
everybody and I look at her and I tried
to be respectful and saying well you
know anybody can get cookies you know
it's not Miss Lisa which was the tech is
really cool she's not bothered by that
and um
she what does she say the girl looked at
me and she said I told you not to do it
and I looked at her and I said I'm
allowed to get snacks when I want to I
said you're not gonna sit here and bully
me over some Oreos and she everybody was
just like kind of like looking around
like I guess she thought that I wasn't
gonna stand up for myself and she was
just yelling like I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to you but when I tell you
something you better listen because I
guess she's trying to what she said you
better listen because I'm old enough to
be your mama and I looked at her and I
said well you're not my mama and you're
not gonna tell me what to do and she
made this ugly face any issues like so I
just looked her and I went back because
that type of stuff is not my nature
either but when you're gonna sit here
and just try and pester me and that
wasn't the only time she had done it you
know her and her little friend had tried
to do it multiple times over just
anything anything I couldn't even sneeze
if she sneezed before me like I couldn't
speak in class without them trying to
make some noise and and make me feel
like I was less than like I remember in
class I said oh I used to not believe in
Jesus and she said oh my god like heard
they were both snickering and stuff and
I was just like what
so this I've been on for the whole time
and I was there in rehab and the reason
I got kicked out was because one of the
girls we were in a Narcotics Anonymous
meeting and you're only allowed to sit
in the first five rows and you know
there's 31 girls and five rows so I set
three rows and like four seats over from
one of those girls one of the mean ones
and she says I can't see and I don't
know who she's not gonna do this are
just keep on and she was like hello I
can't see and I'm sitting I turn around
you know and she's all the way back
there I'm all the way up here you know
you're she's on the fifth row I'm on the
third I'm on this yeah I'm on the second
because I said three in front of her and
she started yelling and she got up got
in my face started cussing at me
specifically said you're not gonna be
here long walked up got her baby and
left and then the program director has
he's like we're in the auditorium
there's two doors his office is right on
the other side of this left-hand door
and I hear her crying saying that I'm
bullying her and I'm being mean to her
and within two hours after that
happening he pulls me aside and he says
you need to pack your belongings
and they were gonna drop me off on a
street corner with all of my stuff they
said you know we can't do anything for
you we have we can't help you get and I
said well if you're gonna kick me out
you can't give me like a couple days to
figure out where to live you know this
is the I was supposed to live at this
rehab for 90 days I made at 21 and he it
was unfair because he did no
investigating no talking to other people
in class to see what had really happened
because if he would if he would have
known that everybody saw that she got up
and got in my face but I was a problem
so I didn't getting kicked out and I
called my mom and she was really upset
because she she thought that I had done
some things and I told her like mom I
didn't do anything they're bullying me
and my mom had known when I had been
there and that exact same rehab when I
was pregnant I was bullied a lot as well
um I get I get bullied a lot of places
that I go out here on the streets you
wouldn't imagine how bad I get it I can
walk I can walk by a female's tent a
female and her boyfriends tent to go to
that store right there to get a soda and
walk back in that same direction right
in front of her and the shoe will
straight up get out of our tents start
yelling at me and tell me she's gonna
beat me up if I don't get moving along
and I'm looking at her like I don't know
who you are I don't know who are you
yeah I'm just I'm going to get a drink
it's good you said that yeah I'm just
like it's just ridiculous the way that
people act sometimes you know and so I
remember when my mom was like that makes
no sense why wouldn't he talk to other
people in class why wouldn't he do this
and this and that and I said mommy you
know what I don't know what I really
thought about it I think the reason why
they kicked me out instead of her was
because she had her newborn child with
her but that's still unfair you know I
should not have gotten kicked out like
that they should have found her another
program to go to so anyways I ended up
getting picked up and nowhere to go my
my mom and dad picked me up and my son
was
home with my grandpa and grandma and
they ended up you know I was so scared
because I I didn't think I was ready I I
I felt like you know how many how can I
possibly stay clean now you know Here I
am super upset I'm I'm having constant
PTSD episodes every other day I can't
sleep at night because I'm I'm waking up
screaming I'm having nightmares I I had
no clue what to do like it was just I
honestly thought you're not gonna make
it Ronnie
you're not gonna make it just give up
this is it you know you tried so oh well
at least we tried Ronnie you can just
keep walking along who cares now and I
remember I got in the car and uh I told
my mom and dad and I said I'm scared and
you know they're like Lisa you know what
do you mean and I said I don't I don't
know if I'm gonna make it and the place
I was gonna go was one of my friends and
he was a very good friend you know we've
been friends since high school and he
him and I had both gone through
addiction together and he's he was clean
now and you know with his apartment and
he was had a job he was doing good now
the problem with staying there was it
was a it was about a 20-minute walk from
the apartment it's my drug dealer
that the that's no that's like the worst
position I could put myself into that's
like me asking to just be tormented
every single day am I like that I wake
up you know and I just told my mom I
said I can't go there mom I can't go
there and she said what do you mean you
can't go there I thought you said it was
a good place I thought you said he was
clean I thought you said it was he you
know everything was good there's no
drugs there and I said yeah there's no
drugs there but there's drugs 20 minutes
down the street and she ended up making
some phone calls and finding a friend
that I could stay with again until I got
into rehab and I ended up doing that and
I've steady waiting on course steady
waiting on court for my CPS so that I
can go to you know I can get my son back
and I can live back at home with my
parents tell like so I can start working
and get on my feet again and it so I
spent every single day at that rehab at
Nexus you know they have a program
called the recovery resources and you're
allowed to go up to Nexus and hang out
with them every single day all day if
you want to you know and that's what I
did I got on five different buses and
trains to get from Granberry to Dallas
to hang out a this recovery Resource
Center just to stay clean and everybody
was like why'd you come all the way up
here and you know it's - it's a two-hour
drive so you know imagine having to get
picked up by my father on his way to
work because he worked in
downtown Fort Worth pick me up drive all
the way to downtown Fort Worth then me
having to walk two miles to get to the
train station hop on the train go all
the way to Dallas get off of that train
walk a little bit to go on to the other
train get on that train go walk a little
bit to get to the bus stop to go to go
all the way to another bus stop and then
get picked up by another bus to finally
get dropped off like a couple blocks
down and I me ended up having to walk
from that last bus stop all the way to
Nexis just to stay clean you know and
the thing is is uh they they say you
know if you can go through all of these
things to get dope you can go through
all of these things to stay clean and
that's what I did I I did that daily
every single day and the recovery
resources coaches they ended up giving
me a bus pass so I didn't have to pay to
be able to come up here you know cuz it
was hard for me to have to pay the bus
fare and the train fare and then when
I'm hungry try and find something to eat
you know so they ended up getting me a
little Regional Fair which is buses and
trains and like other I don't remember
what the other one was and I did that
for quite some time now in between that
I I'm not gonna lie I definitely had
some weak moments and I had relapsed one
day and I called my mom and I said I
need you to come get me you know like I
relapsed and she came got me and they
took me back to the family friends
and cuz at this point I'm still I'm
still allowed to live there but I
finally finally finally got visitation
rights and I remember oh my lawyer told
me like yeah you can see your son now
I'm like oh like I'm just so just oh man
I missed my son so much and he I
definitely believe he is the only reason
that I'm still alive if I didn't have
him I don't think I'd have a reason you
know I my self-esteem it has its days
now where it's getting a lot better but
I have those days where I struggle with
my PTSD and my my bipolar and you know
it's just I got to a point where I
didn't remember a lot like I didn't
remember when the last time I I showered
because I've been wearing the same
clothes for three four or five days
which is gross but that is what that
that is what my depression looks like
you know it can take ahold of me and
that grip that it has is so tight that
I'm just I feel restricted you know I'm
stuck I
I have no I have no willpower to move to
ice I mean I'm the only reason I was
breathing is just because I am I asked
you and my body just does it by itself
if I actually had to physically like do
something for me to breathe I wouldn't
do it yeah II gave it up and I I think
that when the the video came out I had
no clue that it it had even been out you
know I I thought you know I had thought
about it but I never knew you know what
your channel was or anything and uh that
was uh the day that it happened what was
it see I think it was gin no I think I
found out in February and that is when
my mom text me and she said are you
ready
and I'm like ready for what and she says
your YouTube interview is trending and I
said oh it's not shut up I mean whatever
what do you really need to tell me and
she sends me the screenshot of all of
these people that have been sending it
to her because she had no idea either
and all these people like you know I
could get on the Facebook and there's my
face she get on Facebook oh there's my
face there's my face again scroll swirl
it up there's my face again and it was
like everybody that I knew had seen it
everybody that knew my mom had seen it
and I remember like looking at via the
title and it's saying heroin addict and
I was like oh oh I was like wow that's a
big sucker punch but
in the beginning it was crazy because I
just I thought like the worst the
absolute worst that little voice in my
head that constantly tells me that I'm
not enough that people are judging me
went haywire my thoughts were just like
I thought it was over
it's done everybody's gonna judge me
everybody's gonna hate me everybody's
gonna have something to say about me and
all this negativity just flooded my
entire existence
being you know it was filled with
nothing but negative negative negative
negative and I hadn't even watched the
video
I hadn't even like taking the time just
no nothing because my I was I'm scared
i I there was not one positive thought
in my head not one you know it's like
how can how can that even be you know
how is it that there's not a single good
thing that I can think or say about
myself
how is it
that you know I spend so much time
trying to do positive affirmations and
tell myself I love myself and tell
myself I'm beautiful but when this when
when I saw all those news and all those
people were texting me and messaging me
and I I couldn't I couldn't even
comprehend comprehend anything I ended
up not going home for three days I
didn't talk to anybody for three days I
didn't I didn't respond to anybody it's
nothing I didn't open any messages any
videos any anything no no calls nothing
and though the one person that did help
me through is my friend Chris and he he
had been locked up for a little over a
year herself and I you know I hadn't
talked to him forever you know so when
he was finally out I asked him hey will
you watch this video and tell me what
you think you know
and I said I I need help getting through
this and he did he watched the whole
video and he said Ronnie there's nothing
bad in there he said there there's
nothing wrong with it
and he was saying you know that and that
you know I I was a strong person you
know that I was gonna be okay that you
this this was this was good you know and
after that I finally got the strength to
watch the video and when I did I just I
can remember smiling and you know I read
through some of the comments and you
know just seeing the people that I had
helped seeing the people that you know
we're just saying you know they were
praying for me that they they knew they
didn't know me but that they loved me
and they cared for me and that they
hoped I'd that if I ever read this
comment to know that I'm strong you know
what that and after that my whole
perspective changed I finally realized
that I am somebody that my story and my
past does not define me it is it it is
something that has helped me make who I
am today
but it's not that's not the only thing I
am I'm not just a heroin addict I'm not
just a victim of sexual abuse I am NOT I
am NOT just
a homeless woman you know I I'm somebody
I'm somebody who matters I have people
that care about me I have people that
are looking up to me if that's the right
word you know saying I there's this one
comment that I was saying and it said
I'm 20 28 hours into heroin withdrawals
and she said after watching this video
he really helped me not relapse you
really helped me see you helped me stay
strong to get through another day of
withdrawal and she said thank you so
much and that was the one that stuck out
a lot and then of course you know you
have the people that are like she's evil
I I don't know who it was but someone
says I'm in the porn industry I don't
know if you ever saw something yes and I
was just like 40 40 percent of it is not
right my mom was like the porn industry
and I was like right I remember one day
she called me she said hey mom what are
you doing I said oh you know I'm just
making mine I'm about to make my next
porn video and you so I'm gonna end up
being a little funny joke but once once
I saw that like I just you know I can't
honestly I can't thank you enough for
helping me to do that because that was a
lot of stuff that had been boiling in
inside of me these are things that had
been just pestering me on a daily basis
that I am I have been trying so hard to
just keep out of my head you know these
are the things that I just don't want
people to know that I that I think are
gonna tarnish me
and they didn't you know it I didn't it
up helping me dust myself off and and
stand up I now have more motivation to
stay clean to be there for my son to I
want to go to school now I I thought I
was gonna be a drug a heroin addict for
the rest of my life which I am once an
addict always an addict you know I
remember telling my mother I'm never
gonna stop using so you should not to
get over it you know I'm either gonna
die from an OD or something I said but
these drugs are just gonna end up
killing me you know and how in the world
can I say something like that to my
family but now it's like I feel like I
have a lot more hope you know is it was
like that little spotlight that you've
helped put on me has helped me grow
tremendously and I'm not ashamed of it
anymore I think the secret to doing
these kind of talks and putting them on
YouTube for the entire planet to see
right is it allows you to take full
responsibility for everything and the
more the more open and honest you are as
you were and a lot of people I talked to
are you lay it out and all kinds of
people are gonna make negative comments
that some are getting like positive
comments that are beautiful and
compassionate but whatever the case
you're just laying all your garbage out
in the Sun for everyone to look at
forces you to take a look at it and take
responsibility for it and then you can
decide to do differently if you choose
to you don't have to you can go back to
using you can go back to living like a
rat on the street or you can say wow you
know if I if I choose differently
I can end up with a different result I
can maybe get back with my son I can
maybe go to school I can maybe get a job
I can get a better quality life I can
then you can move forward and do that
but the only way you're ever gonna do
that is by putting it out in the Sun and
making everybody look at it yeah that's
right I was power by hiding it it has
power over you and by exposing it it
loses its its control area mm-hmm
and yeah that that all of those things
definitely had a strong hold over me and
they just don't anymore you look totally
different they just I'm not I'm not I
don't spend all my time constantly upset
in my room crying by myself I don't I
don't I don't have as many negative
thoughts I don't have all it's just like
all this hurt that I that I feel all the
time
hurts a little less and each day I feel
like I'm getting a little bit better I'm
I'm making progress
each and every day whether it's whether
it's just somebody saying hey Ronnie
what's up you want to hang out and me
knowing you know if I hang out with them
I'm gonna get high and just saying no
you know what I'm good
and going to do something else you know
going to swim going to bowling going to
just whatever to get myself away from
that you know where I'm now making more
friends I'm going to a church group with
my mother and other women you know
they're all older than me I'm the
youngest one there but they feed a lot
into me and I just it's crazy because
even my mom and dad see it you know
people that have known me since I was 15
see it they see the happiness that I
have now you know I had one of my family
friends I've known her since I was 16
and she was telling me you know he's
just glowing you know you're just you
can tell that you're trying
you know you're you're beautiful in and
you care more about the things that
matter you're putting more effort into
being with your son with your family
with with the people that are important
to you that are gonna help me grow and I
just I love it I do now don't get me
wrong I have my days where I just I hate
everything I ate myself I don't think
I'm gonna you know like I have that
little bad voice again that says what do
you think who do you think you are what
oh because you've almost got 2 million
views on YouTube you think you're
somebody you think people care you think
you're actually you actually have a
chance to to make a youtube account now
and and start talking about these things
that other people don't want to talk
about to start healing and sometimes I
say you're right stupid this is a stupid
idea but those days are less and less
and less so on Monday I have court with
CPS my final court hearing and I'm
looking into this thing called
contemporary can temporary
conservatorship something like that and
that is where I temporarily sign my
rights over to my family so that I can
get myself together
you know I'm looking into this program
it's a year-long you spend the first 90
days in lockdown facility treatment you
know like and then after that they get
you an apartment fully furnished
everything and as the year goes on you
know you get a job I help you save money
you don't pay rent
they may help you get a car they help
you do all of these things and you know
before I would have never ever ever ever
ever wanted to go to a year-long program
at all like year of rehab but I mean
I've spent more than a year rehabbing
all the times I'm gone yeah we have but
now I have more motivation I have more
self-love or self-care than I ever have
and a lot of it was because of that
video it's just it's crazy how how
because I mean I knew that I had done
the video and that you know and all of
those things but once I actually saw it
it's like a light switch went on and I'm
super thankful for that so your video is
the only one to teach two teenage
daughters and your videos the only one
that I've asked them what really was it
because the the bully anger it's just
everything a lot of the stuff you talked
about his stuff that a lot of people
deal with nothing not the heroin
addiction
you can delete that whole part your talk
is still powerful great and that's the
part I wanted to listen to nothing up
there the drug part but the all the
other stuff I thought was super
interesting mm-hmm and I think it's a
lot of things it's stuff that a lot of
people struggle with go through you're
still going through it at rehab crazy
right do that to each other that you
know I'm 22 years you know social media
yeah I see it all the time like you'll
see these hateful comments like what
what do they think they're accomplishing
mm-hmm
well sure they don't understand what
they're actually you're doing is hurting
themselves more than theirs their target
but they spread it right like I watched
a video and it's something I don't want
to watch I just turn it off and never
watch it again
I wouldn't spend the time to make a
negative comment right go through them
watch the whole 46 minutes and then just
to say something I see that I understand
that but it goes on mm-hmm but the best
thing to do is just ignore it yeah and
I'm getting not only just like in the
comments but people are people are going
out of their way to find me on social
media and just say I know you don't know
me but thank you or I think you would
really like this song or you know I'm
not a heroin addict but like you said
take the heroin addiction part out but I
was bullied I do have low self-esteem I
do you know just so much that we have in
common and and just actually seeing that
I helped other people just by talking
just by using my voice and it's just is
crazy
it was amazing so you're thank you and
that first talk to you did was really
powerful and interesting that's could be
I just think it could be really helpful
to a lot I'm sure has been that's why I
suppose yeah so I'm thinking about
starting my own little blog yeah you
should do it anyway so I don't know turn
this into something bigger yeah that's
that's what is that
wait uh public speaking oh yes so tell
me wait it was today Thursday Wednesday
on Friday night I'm going to do a a
which Alcoholics Anonymous and they
asked me yesterday night if I wanted to
speak because they they watch your
videos as well and you know they just
want to talk to me ask questions ask and
Oh Friday night it's gonna be a busy
night it's gonna be very busy meaning so
I'm I'm nervous because I've never ever
spoke like at a meeting before like even
just like regular yeah so just like even
regular like I I can't speak cuz I'm
just like oh my god I sound so dumb but
no you're right now I've always thought
like oh that would be really cool to
speak like and to tell your to tell your
story to do that and I've never ever
been asked to tell my story in a or a
you have great insight some great things
to share thank you so now I was like ah
and I was like I don't know when he was
like you don't have to tell me right now
just tell me by the end of the meeting
and I was just like oh and then I went
over there I was like okay I'm gonna do
it I got it I would talk you into it
he did right so I'm I'm pretty I'm very
excited I
I first sure see a lot of positive
things coming my way and it's just it's
it's a beautiful feeling because of the
destruction and the hurt and the things
that not only other people have put me
through but those are things that I put
myself through you know constantly
hating myself constantly wanting to die
constantly just feeling like nothing and
now it's like sometimes even when I have
that little Ronnie you're not gonna make
it this you know that you're just cuz
just cause a lot of people are giving
you good feedback and all this and that
on YouTube doesn't mean anything and I
it does means a lot and each day I just
got to keep on pushing and keep on
letting myself know that I'm worth it
you know I have a voice and I'm gonna
use it so I'm I'm hoping on going to
school to be a counselor so I'm so happy
for you
thank you thank you thank you all thank
you I'm proud of you thank you I'm very
very happy yes they're the difference
between
you